kimberly has been through a lot with the
guys she's been with especially kanye
caitlyn jenner says kanye west made kim
kardashian's life difficult you watch
your daughter's date very publicly
whether it's your stepdaughters the
kardashians
kylie kendall and they don't date like
normal guys while discussing the dating
lives of the kardashians the 72 year old
reflects on the challenges of kim's
relationship with her estranged husband
kanye
kimberly has been
through a lot with the guys she's been
with you know
very and
especially kanye very complicated guy i
really like tanya i got along with him
so well two of us did great together
and through when even when i
transitioned he was so on my side and
you know loving it but he was very
difficult to live with caitlyn also
reveals her thoughts on how kim's new
man pete davidson compares to kanye pete
is 180 degrees the other direction
as she raves about having a comedian in
the family we need a comedian in the
family
we don't need more rappers we need
comedians in the family she goes on to
share what it was like meeting pete for
the first time and her take on how he
treats kim
peters
they came over the other day because i
told him kim i haven't even met him yet
so she brought him over and they we
spent a couple hours here at the house
together
and
very
different than what she would normally
date but first of all he treats her so
well
and when they were over here
kim is so happy
and kim deserves to be happy
she's been through a hell of a lot in
her life a hell of a lot you know and
she deserves happiness kaitlyn's
thoughts may include kim's divorce from
kanye in february 2021
and despite a lot of drama that's
publicly played out
they have been committed to raising
their four little ones no matter
what we're going through i always want
my kids to
be around their dad as much as possible
and
just to have their mornings with dad and
get dropped off at school
when it comes to kim and pete they've
been dating since october of 2021 and
the happiness he brings her is evident
on saturday kim showed pete's support in
a special way as he bid farewell to
saturday night live after eight years
the mama four shared this collage on
instagram of pete's appearances on snl
the place where they kicked off their
romance during her hosting debut
last month the source told et that kim
is head over heels for pete and when we
spoke with her she revealed what it is
about him that has her falling
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing it's the best
because you can do everything with
totally but it's crazy to be distracted
with people you can be with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing just yeah
running errands just
i don't know right life
[Music]